فرحه كبيره تعبر عنها الجماهير السعوديه
بعد فوز منتخبها على منتخب الارجنتين
بنتيجه 2-1 كما نشاهد هنا في مدينه الخبر
الجماهير كلها خرجت الى شوارع للاحتفال
بهذا الفوز التاريخي منذ انطلاق صادره
النهايه حتى ساعات المساء والجماهير كلها
موجوده في الشوارع احتفالا في هذا الفوز
التاريخ يعني جدا جميل من المنتخب
وافراد المنتخب
الحمد لله بفوز الجميل هذا اليوم متفائل
مباراه المكسيك وبولندا
16 وان شاء الله دوري ثمانيه كمان
والسعوديه جده وقدود
كيف شفت المباراه اليوم مباراه الحمد لله
يعني ما كانت متوقعه بس هذا اللي يستهتر
في السعوديين هذا اللي هذا اللي يجيه هذا
اللي يجيء ايش تقول ميسي اقول ميسي والله
نار
ههه
بس اليوم وانا سعودي اسفه والله
نتيجه كبيره متى حسيت انه المنتخب السعودي
ممكن يفوز المنتخب مو بسيط
وفقدنا الامل في الهدف الثاني اللي كانت
تسلل بس من بعد الحمد لله بعد ما الغوه
الشوط الثاني ادينا ممتاز وما خيب ظن
الناس الضغط
[موسيقى]